I've got a burning question I wanted to
ask you at the beginning of the show Ron
and I'll ask you now if you had the
internet in 1976 before you ran for
Congress would you have started a
YouTube channel instead
I had trouble starting it in 1982 or
1992. I know I'm not it I think about it
in theory and in principle and usage and
the practicality on how you get the
information out in my job I spend most
of my time is trying to understand
things that's why I was fascinated with
just the fundamentals of Economic Policy
if it was the Leonard Reed in the
foundation for economic education to me
this was exciting and I used to Kid
myself I said boy I'm sure glad I found
these people that agree with me